mil 500 indígenas venidos de distintos
territorios se concentran en la
universidad del valle están decidiendo
qué van a hacer si marchan a protestar a
bogotá a la capital o si se quedan en
cali son la conocida como minga la minga
social y comunitaria es una minga que ha
caído muy bien en la opinión nacional
puesto que fortalece el ejercicio de la
democracia porque allí en la minga no
hay presidentes no hay jefes no hay casi
casi es la minga es el colectivo
entre los indígenas de la minga está
feliciano valencia senador de la
república de colombia se dirige a sus
compañeros cuenta que en los territorios
llevan décadas de resistencia
el pueblo colombiano se está moviendo a
pesar de que los medios masivos dicen
que la concentración está en medellín en
bogotá y en cali las veredas los
corregimientos las cabeceras municipales
las vías prácticamente están movilizadas
y bloqueadas en este momento la mina
siempre va acompañada de la guardia
indígena son los encargados de la
seguridad de las comunidades están
acostumbrados a defenderse de grupos
ilícitos paramilitares narcotraficantes
guerrilleros e incluso de la fuerza
pública detrás de nosotros pues han
caído muchos compañeros guardias han
sido asesinados por los diferentes
grupos armados entonces eso nos motiva y
nos llena más de fortaleza para seguir
resistiendo en todos los espacios y en
todos los escenarios
la minga decide salir a las calles de
cali consideran que es el epicentro de
la resistencia de colombia uno de sus
líderes comunica que saben cuándo llegan
pero no cuando vuelven un compromiso que
se vuelve grito el grito de la mina
[Música]